oh yeah
today is the big day for these two
fellas
Harvest Time
they've reached their potential or what
I'd like them how large I'd like them to
be I'm guessing they're
right around 300 maybe just over
so
getting ready to go over and
Harvest them both
we'll head over to my friends with them
here and we have our own processing
facility that we have built and so go
ahead and get them taken care of
well it turns out both of these Hogs
weighed exactly 300 pounds that's pretty
amazing that they came out exactly the
same
as you can see here we don't scald and
scrape our Hogs we just go ahead and
skin them it's a much simpler process
for us this way
two pigs hanging in the cooler
they both weighed exactly 300 pounds
pretty amazing anyway in exactly the
same
you're wondering why that one's hanging
a little different than the others
because somebody made a mistake cutting
off that hind leg and cut that
Achilles tendon or whatever you want to
call it where you normally hang them
like
this right here
I won't mention any names but it was me
anyhow so we've got two pigs hanging in
the cooler and we'll go ahead and get
them processed and packaged tomorrow
[Music]
guys
time to make some sausage
we grind our sausage twice and this is
the second time through this helps get
it into a finer consistency as well as
mix all the seasoning in
two pigs fill up a freezer not quite all
the meat
it's most of it well
it's a good portion of the meat but I
still have a whole
pile of the sausage to put in here
actually none of the sausage is in here
at the moment so there's another
80 pounds of sausage to go in here so
that will fill this freezer
completely full and this is a 7.1 cubic
foot freezer so two 300 pound Hogs will
fill
a 7.1 cubic foot freezer
pretty much right to the
brim and that doesn't include the lard
or the bones that I'm going to use for
bone broth
so including that two whole 300 pound
pigs would not fit in this freezer they
would definitely overfill it this is
what
two processed pigs look like in the
freezer
[Music]